The unrest sweeping across China as citizens rise up in mass protests...
...against severe Covid restrictions.
Some are now calling for China's president to step down.
Maggie Rulli has the story.
Maggie, this is unprecedented.
Yeah, Amy, exactly.
These are on a nationwide scale that we haven't seen for decades...
...and some now even calling for the Chinese leader to step down.
This morning the biggest wave of unrest to hit mainland China in decades...
...is ripping across the country.
Fed up with the government's strict zero Covid policies,...
...thousands have taken to the streets from Shanghai to Beijing...
...and at dozens of universities across the country,...
...shouting, "We want democratic rule of law, we want freedom of speech."
Many holding up blank pieces of paper, the symbol of the growing movement...
...designed to avoid arrest and call out censorship...
...as they protest the lockdowns.
And some in Shanghai calling for the country's president, Xi Jinping, to step down.
A rare and brazen act of public defiance against the communist government...
...and on a nationwide scale not seen across China,...
...since the days of the Tiananmen Square protests in 1989.
The protest triggered by a deadly apartment fire last week...
...in the western city of Urumqi, killing ten.
Many blaming Covid restrictions for the fire department's slow response time,...
...something the Chinese government denies.